without further ado let me introduce
stefan
zeider stefan is a professor
at the university of uh vienna
and uh the tu sorry the tu
technical university of my apologies and
he's the head of the algorithms and
complexity group there
stefan uh has done extensive work in
parameterized complexity theory
as well as set solving cp solving etc
and he has won many awards for his work
including a best paper award
at cp 2020 and an erc
starter grant in 2009 uh so
without further ado uh stefan the floor
is yours thank you
okay thank you vijay for the nice
introduction
and also thanks for for having me here
um yeah so let's
jump to the subject i'll also
talk about things i think very quite
related to
what jordi also was talking about and i
think last week we also had some talks
in this direction um just to
i think there's nothing on this slide
nothing new for any of us
just to i want to kind of press my
my finger into the wounds um that
on the one hand subservers routinely
solve
large instances however
at least the classical uh computer
science theory
um somehow for that sat
is still quite a hard problem so we
heard also about the eth
strong edh etc so there is a certain
theory practice gap
and there is basically a big elephant in
the room
between the theory and the practice and
i think
also is one of the the aims of this
workshop to bring
these two things together so it's a
common wisdom that a real world
such instance contains some kind of
structure some hidden structure
which is implicitly utilized by the
solvers
and the question is can we also modify
the theory
to utilize this structure
so for defining structure mathematically
there are
maybe one can come divided into two main
approaches there are there's the
approach where we try to capture
structure in a way
that statistically correlates with cd
cell solving time
there are variants of this maybe we only
want to have a structure where we can
say okay at least
that instances that come from from
industry
have this kind of structure but also
i think we heard in the previous talk a
few examples for that
i also would like to put into the pool
features
uh for hardness prediction that for
instance come out of of
tools like satzilla which are also
predicting the hardness of the formula
and
do it quite well besides these
correlational models there are models
that i would like to call rigorous
models
that are models where we try to capture
structure in a way
that provides us the means to give
better worst case performance guarantees
for sat algorithms
so it's still worst case but worst case
subject to the existence of a certain
structure
in the instance and i will actually
mostly talk about
the second part the second approach
in this talk of course these both
approaches have pros and cons
i think these rigorous models are not
very well suited for
necessary for explaining the performance
of cdsl
algorithms because certain types of
structures would need
maybe certain types of algorithms and
it's not clear whether the cd cell
algorithm
is suitable for the task but in some
cases this is still
kind of an open open question
um on the other hand the
correlational models provide insights
into
city cell solving so
but on the other hand if you have new
algorithms
maybe in the future i don't expect that
a completely new algorithm
will win the next sub competition but
maybe
over in the in the
future far ahead maybe there could be
imaginable some kind of a portfolio
where
next to a cdcl solver maybe for some
instances there is
a different type of solver and um
yeah but i'm now mainly focusing on the
on a theoretical framework the
complexity framework for
analyzing uh structural properties of
fat formulas in this
rigorous way and um
now let's think of uh such a framework
so
this this blue dots represent such
instances
and in the x-axis we have the instance
size
and in the y-axis we would now like to
to put
a second dimension which somehow
characterizes how much
structure uh in the instance has
um with respect to a certain view what
we consider a structure
and we can now take a parameter let's
say p
of f where f is the formula which
assigns the formula
in integer and the larger the instant
integer the less structure is there so
closer smaller this parameter
the the faster an algorithm ideally can
can run and now we should have run time
guarantees
worst case runtime guarantees that
depend on both
this parameter k and the instance size
now is the question how shall we kind of
combine
instant size and parameter
and so the first try would be starting
from the idea that
when the parameter constant yes the
question from karum
the question is what is instance size
okay instant size
is just um you can take the sum
of the cardinalities of the clauses
which is basically the the the
the size of the of the of the dimex
formula more or less
so of course for some things it's if
it's reset you can also take
just the number of variables but in
general the number of clauses can be
exponential in the number of variables
so it's just the
length sometimes it's called the length
of the formula
okay um so if k the parameter is a
constant then the runtime should be
polynomial
this would lead us now to such a model
where we say
okay we take some function f of k
this can't be in the exponent and when k
is a constant this is polynomial
runtime but i don't think this is a
an ideal setting because just think of
if even if
f is the identity function then
if the parameter value is one okay then
it's linear time
if it's two then it's quadratic time
that then we get
to cubic time to to um
quartic time etc so this will
not scale very well and by k equals five
it's very hard to argue that uh this is
still
something you would call tractable so
the
um second try um now takes
this function of the parameter k
in front as a factor so it contributes
to the over running time
by a constant factor however uh
the instant size is now the runtime is
now a polynomial in the instant size
and the order of this polynomial
remains constant independent of the
parameter
and now this scales much better and this
form of of a running time function in a
two-dimension
two-dimensional setting is called fixed
parameter tractable
uh running times or short fbt
and um this distinction between fpt
and non-fpt running times is actually
for um a very turned out to be a very
uh nice and very deep um
consideration where you can build a very
interesting
algorithmic theory and complexity theory
upon it and this is for instance
witnessed by this
five textbooks that have been published
over the last 20 years
so there is a rich theory that has been
developed with
very nice algorithmic and complexity
theoretic ideas
at this point let me also advertise the
second edition of the handbook of
satisfiability which is about to
uh to appear and there is also the
chapter on fixed parameter tractability
which has been extended
and revised since the first edition and
actually
most of the content of this talk you
will find in this chapter so
i also references i didn't want to
clutter up my slides too much with
references
so you can also find the references in
there
okay one aspect that also makes uh the
this fixed parameter tractability
setup nice from the theoretical point of
view
because we also have a hardness theory
so if we
cannot come up with an fbt algorithm for
a problem
then we have a toolbox of giving strong
theoretical evidence
that this problem did not that no such
algorithm exists
similar to np hardness uh gives strong
evidence
that not a polynomial algorithm doesn't
exist
so here we have um
b time then fbt and this
uh bolt black line is the interesting
line between boss is fbt and what is not
and there we have this infinite
hierarchy of complexity classes wi
and showing hardness for one of these
classes gives us this evidence so i
don't want
can go here more into detail but in the
during my talk sometimes some
w i hardness result would turn up and
then
you know this problem most likely
is not fixed prominent attractive
okay now uh we have this permit rest
complexity toolbox
how can we apply this to that
and um now um there are two
basically two ways so let me first press
it present i think the the
nicer and the more more profound way so
assume we have is an
input a formula f and an integer k
this k is supposed to bound the
parameter under consideration and now
our algorithm
can terminate with these three options
it can either say
f is satisfiable it can say f is
unsatisfiable
or it can say sorry
the parameter for this formula exceeds
our budget of k
and this is nice because here we
circumvent
that the algorithm exactly recognizes
all the instances um where the parameter
value is
at most k so here in this picture
uh think of this rectangle contains
exactly the instance where the parameter
value is
k or smaller but it can just decide
maybe there are some
easy instances where satisfiability is
easy to decide
outside this box where the algorithm
doesn't need to bother to decide whether
this instance belongs inside or outside
the box so this is
i think the the so-called permissive or
robust approach
in practice often we cannot avoid doing
the two phases approach where we in the
first phase we
try to find the structure explicitly so
we have a
verification or recognition algorithm
and then once we have this structure
found
or we can reject at this stage if the
parameter exceeds
a k then we apply our sub algorithm
that that exploits or utilizes the
structure that has been revealed
revealed in the first part
so uh also here this uh two phases
approach can also be slightly relaxed
because
uh the witness um generated in the first
phase it doesn't need to be optimal
like when we work with parameters we can
always make an error which is
a function of the parameter so we can
also do a so-called fbt approximation
which is also fine because um the
sat algorithm will still be an fbt
algorithm it will be just
maybe a little bit slower
and now um in i think a very fundamental
and important
concept is the concept of dominance we
can say that if you have two
sub parameters b and q we can say that
b dominates q if
basically for all instances if
q is bounded then also b is bounded
so basically we can get rid of q
because b does the same job as
sq and again here is this f of q
of f because um
we can always apply a a function
to a parameter and now this gives
it this b domination this domination is
a little bit similar to
these simulation of proof systems when
you have propositional proof systems you
can also
arrange them in a diagram where you
order them by b simulation and
it's very similar here and this gives
rise to a general research program
to come up with stronger and stronger
parameters and
draw this a map of the parameters into a
mutual dominance
and then we can try to find more
more general parameters maybe some will
be
incomparable but um
this um and that's basically what i in
the next
the reminder of my talk i want to give
you an overview of
what is known in this uh in this line of
research
final question uh so do you have
formally speaking you have no
requirements on this function f
you'd be totally happy if it's like a
tower of exponentials
you still consider the second measure to
dominate the first
yes it should be computable
okay um there is uh like
one could also related to this question
is
that when you say a problem is fixed
parameter tractable it's fbt
then there can also this this f of
k in the front of your running time it
can also be a power of two
but um it um has been
um there are many examples where like
the first algorithm
fbt algorithm that has been proposed for
a problem had it
quite an ugly uh parameter dependence
and then later on would could see
a continuing improvement and algorithms
could
be improved significantly
okay now i would want to present like
three groups
of uh or three classes of of
parameters facade parameters based on
the graphical structure of the instance
parameters based in a certain sense on
the syntactical structure
and then a rather short
section at the end of matt talk hybrid
models where we
combine basically one and two
and for the graphical structure we first
need to fix the graph by which we want
to represent
our formula and now i
i realize there is of course a little
bit of an overlap to
to other dogs we have seen i think
geordie mentioned two graphs
i will mention how many five or six
just to give you an overview um the the
primal graph
i think is the most common one you have
every vertex is available and you join
two variables if they appear together in
the clause
related to this is also the hyper graph
where
basically each clause gives you a hyper
edge
then there's the dual graph it's
actually a very interesting graph as
well
where now your vertices are the clauses
and
two clauses are are adjacent
if they con they overlap
in at least one variable here we don't
distinguish between
positive and negative occurrence there
are two variants of it the conflict
graph where you only
make an edge if the two clauses have a
conflict have conflicting literals
and the consensus graph where you
draw an edge between two clauses if
there is no
conflict so it's the complement graph of
the conflict graph
last not least the incidence graph or
also called
a clause variable incidence graph it's a
pipette
graph of variables and clauses and you
have an edge
between a variable and the clause if the
where appears in the clause
there's also this variant of the
directed incidence graph
where you orient an edge depending order
of
whether the variable appears positively
or negatively in the clause
the directed incidence graph is up to
isomorphism
a full representation of your instance
where the other graphs
to some extent abstract away some
information
and now we have all these graphs and
then we now we can apply
some standard graph parameters and see
whether
we can um say something about this
satisfiability problem
and of course the kind of canonical
uh invariant you would consider is
three bits and um so therefore
a very one slide uh definition of three
bits i think we have heard it last week
before therefore it can be quick
you have a graph a 3d composition is now
a tree
where each node of the tree is a set
or also called the back of vertices of
the graph
there are certain properties this
decomposition needs to satisfy
and the width of this decomposition is
the size of the largest bag minus one
so in this case a largest size is three
and
so the width of this decomposition is
two the three bits of the graph is now
the smallest width over all its three
decompositions
and what's very convenient
that checking whether a graph has three
bits
at most k is fixed parameter tractable
in k
so we can basically assume that when we
take the tributes of any of these graph
models of the formula
that in fbt time we can decide whether
indeed this uh graph has a three bits at
most k
and produce also a witnessing 3d
composition
okay now um yeah and i here's a reminder
to myself when we talk about three bits
of a formula
i think we should always specify the
graph we are referring to because there
are differences
and um it makes a difference which one
you're talking about and um so therefore
we have then like the primal tributes is
the tributes of the primograph
dual tributes triggers of the dual graph
etc
and the good news is that and i draw
here already
um some part of this diagram
this dominance where an error
points from one parameter to another if
the first
dominates the other so as we see here
the incidence three bits dominates the
primal tributes and the dual triggers
so from this point on principle we could
forget about primal and
dual tributes only work with incidence
tributes
the consensus tributes interestingly is
incomparable
with the other three parameters
um but for all four of them
the satisfiability problem is fbt
we can actually even do model counting
in fbt time
for for these parameters just the
conflict tributes the tributes of the
conflict graph
here the um the satisfiability
uh problem is w bonhart
so it's outside our green green box
um of course next to three bits there
are also other
width parameters for graphs
and here is a bit an overview um
apologize it's a bit cluttered i'll try
to give you
um guide you through this diagram so
here we have the primal tributes
the dual tributes and the incidents
tributes what we discussed before
here i would like to mention the branch
width that's a parameter
uh considered by aleknovich and
raspboros
among others that this is dominance
equivalent with primal tributes
interestingly here above incidence
tributes a stronger
parameter is the the clique width of the
directed
incidence graph it's interesting because
graphs can have bounded liquids even if
there are dents
and also here we have um it's in the
green box so here we have fixed
parameter detectability
dominance equivalent to this is the rank
width of the directed
incidence graph if we look at the
cliques of the undirected incidence
graph then we lose
fixed parameter tractability we only
have xb
and just for
being a bit more complete hypertribits
parameter very well known in the
constraint satisfaction
community and also for database queries
hyperdrives doesn't help in this context
because
already formulas of hypertribits one
are np-hard to solve so stefan there are
a couple of questions from sybil
uh it says are you referring to exact
model counting in fpt like a minute ago
you mentioned model counting
yes so basically everything here in the
green part
you can exactly count the number of
models in fbt time
his next question has to do with
approximate model counting so he says
where does approximate
model counting fall
[Music]
what about approximate model counting
um yeah um so
that means whether for the for the um
the red
uh the parameters in red whether you can
do approximate model counting right
i don't know i
i don't know it depends a little bit on
the uh what's your
uh what approximation uh you
want to achieve but um i i don't know
i rather i'm rather skeptic i don't
i if i have to guess i would rather say
that it's not
possible but i don't want to
give a definite answer i cannot give you
a perfect answer
okay so maybe also i say
for when you talk about model counting
it always says that
this width parameters are quite strong
parameters which
give us a lot of information and we can
give us a lot of algorithmic power so if
you only want to do
such decision then it's a little bit of
a
waste to to use the strong parameters if
you
if you want to put it this way um
okay now let's go to the second class of
parameters
based on the syntactic structure so
here's the idea you have something like
juan formulas
then horn is a tractable class but we
want to
gradually extend horns so we take a base
class
think of it as horn or two cnf and now
you want
to scale the easiness of the
of one formulas to formulas that are not
one
but which are maybe not too far away
from being horn so in other words
we want to parameterize by the distance
of a formula
from being juan formula and
try to get fixed parameter tractability
in this distance
and how do we measure the distance from
being one or belonging to some other
base class
there's a very natural concept for doing
that it's using the size of the smallest
vector set
here i'm referring to so also it's
called strong vector sets which
applied also to unsatisfiable and to
satisfy the instances
what is a vector set let's it's a set of
variables like here in this example this
is
variables x y and z of a formula f
and for all possible assignments of
these three variables so you have in
this case
eight different reduced formulas where
we apply these assignments
after applying all these assignments you
um you get a formula that belongs to
your base class
so you can all these green guys here you
can solve in polynomial time
so in other words when you know a vector
set of size k
they said disability of f reduces to
checking
they said this variability of two to
decay easy instances
so in other words it's fbt if you know
if you know the vector
therefore finding the vector is
the challenging question if you have a
small vector then you can
just apply your your known algorithm
that you that is associated with your
base class
um and also here that the second
disclaimer when we talk about vectors
we should always specify the base class
we are referring to
because it makes a big difference
whether it's a vector to juan or a
backdoor
to renamable horn etc
and here also
our parameter zoo don't get lost in this
zoo let's start
at the bottom um
if we take this parameter the vector
size to horn
then this is a fixed parameter tractable
so we can compute
exactly as small as one vector set in
fpt time the same holds true for
dual horn that's formulas containing at
most one
negative literal and it's also true for
two cnf now above these three base
classes we have now
other base classes that um
contain the the class below it so if
this this lattice we have here is just a
lattice by set
inclusion and if one base class contains
the other
then the vector set parameter for the
one
base class is also dominates the vector
set parameter for the other
and we already see from the green
color here that for these three
fundamental classes
vector detection is fixed parameter
tractable
we can even do it when you look up here
what does it mean one union two cnf
that means if you look here to the left
that when we
do all these two to decay different
partial assignments
sometimes we end up in one formula and
sometimes we end up in the two cnf
formula so
we can basically mix these two
don't mix confuse this with
a formula containing at the same time
horn and two cna formulas
this is of course not a suitable base
class
but here when we look in the red part it
would be here this is renamable horn
this would be nice if we could have this
as a
vector detection fbt time but
unfortunately this w too hard
or here on the top this is the kind of
in this context the most general class
um quadratic one
a class was introduced by andre boros
and colleagues in 1990 it contains
a renamable horn 2 cnf and so forth
but unfortunately here back the
direction here is also w hard
and this leads us now to the concept of
deletion vectors because we want to
weaken the notion of vectors so that we
have access to these more general
classes
and what is a deletion vector set it's
defined as a question by jan
are there any non-trivial dominance
relations here
which are not induced by inclusion of
the base classes
[Music]
i'm not aware of any maybe a mixed
missed one but i'm not aware of any
but maybe if you no one please point it
out but
i don't think there is one
yeah so there was a deletion vector set
yeah it's also a set of variables but
instead of
applying partial assignments to this
vector variables
when we apply partial assignment we also
remove a full clause
if one at least one of its literals is
set to true
um here is a deletion vector we don't
delete
full clauses here we really just pick
out all the literals that correspond
to variables in the vector set so we
only delete these literals and so
these deletion vectors are less
powerful method
but fortunately in most cases for most
base class it holds that when you have a
deletion vector set
then this is also a strong vector
vector as we introduced in the previous
slide
and so therefore we can at least try to
find deletion vector sets with an fbt
algorithm
and good news for
q1 where the standard vectors
can't be found in fbt time if we look at
deletion q1 vector sets we can find them
with an fbt algorithm which is a
relatively complicated algorithm
but it's puts this class which
also contains uh renewable horn etc
puts this into the green part and so
with
looking at deletion vectors it's a bit
of a trade-off we
lose some generality because deletion
vectors are kind of a weaker notion
but we can find deletion vectors
for larger base classes
yeah here is a bit of an intermission
avoid the 2k
assignments so when we have a
vector we consider
of size k we we have to we reduce
the set disability problem to 2 to decay
easy instances now
it can be observed that sometimes you
don't need to
to construct this full binary tree
because you can prune the tree if you or
by by assigning fewer variables of the
vector set
you are already in your base class so
then you
if you're lucky you end up with
something like this where instead of
eight in this case eight uh easy
formulas you only have to solve fourth
and this is now called the vector3
and the size of the vector3 is
enabled to define it in terms of the
number of leaves of the tree
now you can ask can we also find a
vector3
into horn let's say with an fpt
algorithm what makes this problem
slightly
more difficult or actually significantly
more difficult
is that a small inspector tree
might be based on a vector set
which is not a smallest vector set yes
you can't just go over all small
inspector sets and then
try to build a small tree on top of it
but
even worse this vector set might not
even be
subset minimal so
therefore finding it is more complicated
but you can save
an exponential number of of easy
instances that you need
to solve and fortunately
with a more complicated algorithm also
for the use usual suspects for horn
dual horn and two cnf we can also find
pector trees with kale leaves in fpd
time
and we can even mix horn into cnf as we
did
for the vectors and now one more
like an incremental improvement uh
that's a very recent work we
uh considered uh what is if we don't
insist on this tree-like structure
because when you look at it what you
need from these
partial assignments is that they re they
correspond to a full case distinction
that you don't leave out something
and so it suffices that if you take all
this partial assignments that are
associated with the leaves if you
consider this
each assignment as a conjunction of
literals
and the set of these assignments
together is a dnf
then it suffices to consider
tautological dnfs
so every vector3 gives rise to
such a dnf but a dnf can be much smaller
than
a dnf you get from a tree and this gives
the notion of a vector dnf
and also here we can find in fpga time
such smallest back to dnfs into
the usual suspects
okay but now uh if you just look at
vector
trees and vector dnfs from the through
the lens
of of um domination
then you don't gain anything because
the sizes of vector trees uh bacter dns
and vector sets are all
related by a function of the parameter
this can be
a two-to-decay factor improvement which
of course is not something you should
disregard but on the
domination lattice it does not show up
that you made an improvement
okay now i'm already coming to the third
class of parameters the hybrid
parameters
which tried to combine these two
words because we have instances where we
have
a large incidence treatment say so they
are
bad for this decompositional graphical
uh parameters
but where all the the clauses are on so
we have
a horn vector of size 0. so it's easy
for
vector size difficult for
graph width parameters on the other hand
it's also easy to construct
formulas with large horn vector size
for instance it's a tree-like structure
but
all the clauses are non-horn and so you
have to use
a linear number of of
variables in your vector set and
so these two approaches are incomparable
and the hybrid parameters now try to
make a crossover
try to get a parameter that covers pose
there's of course you can always do it
in a cheap way you just say
i take as my parameter the minimum of
the two
incomparable parameters but of course
this is some kind of cheating we want to
have a parameter that
really merges really combines the two
ideas also
on on a local level
and there are two approaches that work
very briefly the first is the idea of
to consider vectors into bounded tree
bits
so we now take as our base class
for a vector um all formulas
where the incidence tree which is
bounded by some constant d
this would be here this uh three bits t
class now we put a vector on top of it
and because here we are dealing with
strong vectors
so not this deletion vectors deletion
vectors wouldn't work
well because this would just increase
the tree bits but
don't give you more power but when you
do it this way with
the strong vectors you really get
something that you can't
do just with three widths alone and
for every constant t we can fbt
approximate the three bits
vector smallest vectors into bounded
three bits
so uh quite a
complicated combinatorial algorithm but
uh
it's it works and it's
fbt approximable the other
um slightly more recent
result is and it's the notion of vector
treats i i find it even kind of more and
more compelling
and then it's the idea that you have a
backdoor but you don't
measure just the size of the vector so
in fact this vector can be large
let's in this figure the blue dots are
now your variables of your vector set
so this is a large spectrum and
into a class c let's think it's horn so
all these green
bulbs are large components of one
clauses
now what do you do next you can
you compress each of these components
and replace the component just with
edges between the variables which were
interacting with the component let's do
this for the
second component as well and for the
third component
now we have a graph that we call the
dorsograph
and we now take the three bits of this
graph
and the vector three bits is now
the smallest three bits you get over
all vectors uh um
for for your formula so and it's not
difficult to see that this
the back door three bits is smaller than
the primal tributes and it's smaller
than any
vector set in the class c
and for our usual suspects
we can show that vector3 bits is
fbt to compute and we can also use it
for
for that solving so the idea
i can't explain the recognition
algorithm but if you
find this structure then you can compile
each component into a constraint
and then you are left with a
csp problem of bounded tributes and
we know that a boolean csp of bounded
primal tributes can be solved in fbt
time
and so therefore we we have
we have the the result
okay here is now the parameter zoo where
i
try now to put a few of dimension
parameters into context
here are the new horn vector three bits
dual one vector3 wheels and two synth
vector3 bits they now really dominate
like one vector tree which dominates one
vector size
and the primal three bits and for the
others
they also do a similar domination then
here on the right hand side we have the
vector into bounded three bits classes
um they give us an infinite chain of
of parameters each is more general than
the other
there is a certain relationship between
this uh
these parameters and the incidence
tributes because
here but we can't really compare them in
terms
of uh of dominance because uh for
incidence
the three which is the parameter we're
here for
three bits for vectors into three bits t
uh the three bits is a constant
and so we can't really compare them um
properly
okay um last but one slide
of course there are some sweater
parameters i didn't have time
uh going into um maybe
of some interest is this maximum
deficiency
parameter which also has some
relationship
to to minimal unsatisfiable formulas
because when you delete from a formula
with pre-processing
this matching order keys then the
maximum deficiency is now
the the difference between the number of
clauses and the number of variables
and in this parameter we can
solve the set disability problem in fpt
time
clustering widths is something where we
have deletion vectors into sets
of variable disjoint heating formulas
i won't explain heating formulas now
and we know some of you know heating
formulas
and h modularity this was
um a parameter which
we came up with it was kind of we
we thought we want to have a parameter
which resembles to some extent
this modularity that's very popular
for describing uh real world
circumstances
i think jordi also talked about it but
we know that for every very high
modularity
the sub problem still remains np-hard we
wanted to come up with something
that has a little bit the same
flavor as modularity but where we have
a but which is a rigorous parameter
in the sense that we have fbt
sat solving in with respect to this
parameter
okay um to sum up um
i hope i could convince you that permit
rest complexity is a
suitable framework for studying rigorous
fbt subparameters
the dominance relation allows us to
explore the subject
systematically and we can try to
come up with stronger and stronger
parameters
however this is an open-ended endeavor
um there's not the
i don't expect that there is a certain
parameter which is then kind of the
dominates everything else so unless p
equals np
if p equals np then uh the constant
parameter 0
dominates all other parameters but
we
i guess we don't believe that so
we can come up with more and more
interesting parameters one avenue i
would be very interested
in but i have not really made much
progress in this direction is
to have parameters that um utilize the
structure implicitly so where we don't
need these two phases approach but
just if we know that a certain
hidden structure is there our sat
algorithm
runs and exploits it similar to
cd sales always do it but with some
proofable performance
guarantee and the last
point here um is also related
to the open problem that i post
last week and one could more generally
one could now look at all these
parameters
that are in the green with the green
background these fpd parameters
and for each of them uh investigate
whether there exists
um the solution proofs of unsatisfiable
formulas
um where the size of the resolution
proof
is fpt in terms of the
considered parameter because if that's
the case
then we would know that in principle a
cdcl algorithm
if it has the right heuristic
makes the right heuristic decisions in
principle could also
run in fpt time on these parameters or
there might be also some negative
results
which then would show uh-huh we have
here a parameter
which in 20 years in our portfolio
we should put this fbt algorithm there
because the cdl solver
won't be able to solve these instances
where our parameters algorithm can solve
it
okay that's everything thank you
happy to answer questions thank you
stefan for a very informative and nice
talk
um i'll start with audits question so
what i had asked
the question is there any measure for
the difficulty of satisfiable instances
i think perhaps what he's
uh thinking about is is there two
different classes of measures
one for onset instances and one for sad
instances
um did i get you get you right ordered
yeah uh you can go ahead stephan yeah so
the answer is
um is simple all the parameters that i
presented here
apply to both satisfiable and
unsatisfiable instances
so gary's i i mentioned that
for instance the the backdoors that i'm
considering
are also called strong vectors there's
also the notion of a weak vector
which only applies to satisfyable
instances so
you don't for a week back though you
don't need to consider all possible
assignments to the pectoral variables
but you only need
one assignment but if you apply this
assignment it should give you
a satisfiable instance in your base
class such a weak vector can be smaller
and it
only makes sense to consider such weak
vectors for
satisfiable instances but um here
in my talk i was focusing me only
focusing on
on parameters that apply to satisfiable
and
unsatisfied instances
okay stefan are you aware of these
back doors called learning sensitive
back doors
from dilkina at all and yes
um i'm aware of this there is also um
also from billikena it all they have
this also interesting notion of vectors
um with um empty clause detection
so that are i think both are extensions
of the vector
um approach but for both
um the the detection uh is not
fbt anymore so for instance the empty
empty clause direction is easy to
describe you say
uh you apply all these partial
assignments to your vector
set but if the assignment produces an
empty clause
then you don't care whether the
reduced formula really belongs to your
base class because
satisfy is trivial there this
seemingly subtle change in the
definition
in practice gives you much smaller
vector sets but
we could show that the detection of
these spectacles is much harder so it's
basically for almost every conceivable
base class
the detection of this vector strong
vectors with empty clause detection
is is
um jody do you want to take uh
take the question by oded
so the question is yeah my question was
in the context of the previous talk that
presented measures of
resolution proofs and i was wondering if
there is an analog of a resolution proof
for a satisfiable instance
i don't know what that would be uh jody
you want to
address uh
i uh i have seen some
notions for for this you mean not the
same notion
when you don't have a refrigeration but
you have uh
because they found the formula is
satisfiable
yeah that uh yeah
what it says yes yeah
there are several possibilities to
extend the notion of of
stroller or harness it was done by a
coleman thing i think coleman was
an attendant maybe he can unwork the
question
better than me
uh yeah
maybe we can take this offline uh yeah
oliver
is in the in attendance i think
oliver can you talk to
odette's question
uh can you unmute yourself oliver or
hello um yes uh can you hear me yeah
um yeah just
yes sir in principle all all of these
unsatisfiability measures can be
extended in various forms
to all cnfs by for example
considering unsatisfiable substances
which are produced by applying partial
assignments
so if you have a measure on hardness for
unsatisfiability
then now you look at an arbitrary
instance and then you look for example
the worst case you could also
use the other complexity measures of
what happens if i hit that formula in
all possible ways
um and then you look at the
unsatisfiable instances produced by it
that's it if you take unit loss
propagation
that then means you um
what however you assign it
unit gross propagation will never fail
in my talk about next weekend we have
something about encoding and workshop
and encoding and
i will tell you a little bit more about
that
thank you oliver uh kuldeep has a
question for stefan
can you comment on parameters for which
we have fpt for np but not for sigma 2p
um i'm i'm i'm guessing what this
question is about um so we
um i i have uh started a few years ago
with
my student ronald tejan a
quite an extensive line of research
where we looked at parameters
that applied to problems that are beyond
np
so in particular problems on the second
level of the polynomial hierarchy
and the idea was to not solve the
problems in fpt time
but find an fpt reduction to an np
problem in other words to solve a
problem that's higher up in a polynomial
hierarchy
using a subserver but using only an
fbt number of calls to the shuttle
and so there we have quite a a long list
of results and also a hardness theory
for
problems where this apparently is not
possible
um yeah this at least this is the only
answer i can give for a question where
we have fbt and b not sigma
by two in in together so i hope this
uh cody please correct me if i was not
answering your question
thank you again stefan for for a great
talk